لمن لا يتذكر كان شيخ الازهر في مقدمه
الذين احاطوا بعبد الفتاح السيسي حين اعلن
الاطاحه بالرئيس المصري المنتخب محمد مرسي
يوم الثالث من يوليو عام
2013 حينها كان احمد الطيب راس اكبر مؤسسه
دينيه في مصر حاجه ملحه للنظام لتلميع
صورته وانجاح الانقلاب اليوم يتعرض شيخ
الازهر لحمله شرسه من وسائل اعلام مقربه
من النظام تطالبه بالاستقاله قبل ان تضيق
عليه الارض بما رحبت فما الذي استجد اذا
في هذا السياق نتابع اولا تقرير محمد
ابراهيم ق ايه يا فضيله الامام تعبتني يا
فضيله الامام
اختصرت تلك العباره التي جاءت بين الجد
والهزل فيما بد العلاقه المتا ازمه بين
الازهر والنظام المصري فهل ما قاله السيسي
هو طلاق شفوي لم يقع على حد طروحاته
الاخيره حول تغيير مسائل الطلاق ام انه
طلاق مكتوب واصبح بائنا وموثقا امام
الشهود في محاكم النظام الحمله العنيفه
التي شنتها وسائل الاعلام المحسوبه على
السلطه على شيخ الازهر احمد الطيب ودعوتها
له للاستقاله توحيان بان صبر السلطات بلغ
حدوده من مشيخه الازهر وان النظام انتقل
من مرحله النقد الى القطيعه او الطلاق
الفعلي الطلاق لم يكن تذمر السيسي خلال
حثه الازهر على عدم الاعتراف بالطلاق
الشفوي في مناسبه عيد الشرطه الا قمه جبل
جليد من الخلاف بين النظام والمؤسسه
الدينيه اقوله يا فضيله الامام انت
بتعذبني فيقول لي انت بتحبني ولا حكايتك
ايه اقوله يا فضيله الامام لا بحبك
وبحترمك وبق درك فمن عبارتي ان ت تعبتني
يا فضيله الامام مرورا بكل ما بشوف الامام
بقول له انت بتعذبني الا ساحا جج امام
الله عبارات كررها السيسي امام قيادات
الازهر في مناسبات مختلفه على مدار
السنوات الثلاث الاخيره توتر العلاقه بين
الدوله والازهر تجسدت نذره في دعوات تجديد
الخطاب الديني او الثوره الدينيه التي من
فك النظام يطرحها بينما كان في المقابل
تمسك الازهر بثوابت يحر عليها ويرى في
الخروج عنها مساسا بقواعد مستقره منذ مئات
السنين كان اذا بمثابه القشه التي قسمت
ظهر العلاقه بين الطرفين وفعليا بدات عدد
من الصحف المصريه بعد خطاب السيسي الاخير
في ممارسه ضغوط على شيخ الازهر الدكتور
احمد الطيب لاجباره على تقديم استقالته من
منصبه وقد صدرت تلك الدعوات بالتزامن
فطالب محمد الباز رئيس تحرير جرير الدستور
في مقال له شيخ الازهر بان يستقيل وتوعده
ان لم يفعل بان تضيق عليه الارض بما رحبت
على حد تعبيره وفي الاطار ذاته نشرت صحيفه
الموجز خبرا مثيرا تحت عنوان استقاله شيخ
الازهر من منصبه وانضمت ايضا صحيفه الوطن
الى قافله مهاجمي شيخ الازهر واتهمته بشكل
صريح هو ومؤسسه الازهر بانهما سبب انتشار
التطرف والارهاب ثمت من يعتقد ان الهجمه
الشرسه على شيخ الازهر رغم تاييده انقلاب
السيسي محاولات من السلطه لت المؤسسه
الدينيه بشكل كامل لسياستها فالسيسي فيما
يبدو ظل يؤرقه تدمر رجال الازهر من بعض
قرارات النظام والاهم انه لم يغفر للطيب
اصداره بيانا تبرا فيه من اراقه الدماء في
مجزرتي رابعه والنهضه وزادت طين بله بين
الطرفين فضلا عن كل ذلك رفض الدكتور الطيب
قرار السلطه اقامه خطبه موحده في البلاد
وتبرئه من مؤتمر الشيشان اخيرا كما رفضه
اصدار بيان يكفر فيه تنظيم ظم الدوله
ويبدو رد بعض الفقهاء ولجان الازهر
واعتبار ما طلبه السيسي من عدم الاعتراف
بالطلاق الشفوي مخالفا لنصوص الشرع واراء
الفقهاء على مر التاريخ كان الامر الذي
حسم فيه النظام طلاقه مع المؤسسه الدينيه
في
البلاد لنقاش الموضوع ينضم الينا عبر
الهاتف من القاهره الدكتور عبد المقصود
باشا استاذ الدراسات العليا في جامعه
الازهر من واشنطن توفيق حميد الباحث في
الشان المصري وفي الاستديو الشيخ محمد
الصغير مستشار وزير الاوقاف المصري السابق
اهلا بكم جميعا دكتور عبد المقصود ابدا
معك برايكم ما سبب هذه الحمله الاعلاميه
الشرسه على شيخ الازهر المطالبه
باستقالته بدايه السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام وعلى ضيفي ك فضيله مولانا الشيخ
محمد الصغير او الضيف من الولايات المتحده
السلام على المشاهدين الكرام بدايه
اقول لا توج يجد حمله من الرئاسه على
الازهر الشريف
فاما ما يقوله بعض
الصحفيين من استقاله شيخ الازهر او هذا
الكلام السيء الهزيل فهو مردود عليهم
فهؤلاء ما فتئوا دائما يسيئون الى الازهر
الشريف ام طوال تاريخهم يسيئون الى تلك
المؤسسه العالميه
ومن يقول ان الارض تضيق على شيخ الازهر
بما رحبت بل الارض تضيق عليه بما رحبت
ويضيق عليه الكون كله
وكور هناك اشاره مهمه هذه الاصوات لم
نسمعها الا بعد انتقادات وجهها الرئيس
السيسي لشيخ الازهر في مناسبات عديده كان
اخرها مقال انت تعبتني يا فضيله الامام
هذه الاصوات لم تاتي من فراغ وهذه اصوات
معروف انها مقربه من المؤسسه العسكريه
وايضا مقربه من نظام الرئيس
السيسي سيدي ا وعين الحب عن كل عيب كليله
وعين البغض تبدي مساوئه ان هذه العباره
التي قالها الرئيس السيسي من باب الدعابه
ولعلك لاحظت واذا كان حضرتك مصري تعرف مدى
الدعابه في الخطاب لدرجه ان القاعه ك كلها
ضجت بالضحك هذه دعابه لا يعرفها الا
المصريون الخلص اما ان يتم هذا او يقال ان
هذا بدايه طلاق فهذا من العقول المريضه
ايضا عفوا دكتور اذا اذا انت فهمتها دعابه
يبدو ان شيخ الازهر لم يفهمها دعابه
واوسطه نقلت بانه مستاء جدا من هذه
التصريحات على كل حال دعني اسال توفيق
حميد سيد حميد ما المطلوب من الازهر اكثر
يعني الازهر شارك في الانقلاب وفي عزل
الرئيس الشرعي المنتخب محمد مرسي وصولا
الى المشاركه في مؤتمر الشيشان المثير
للجدل ما المطلوب من الازهر اكثر حتى يرضي
هذا النظام ورئيس السيس والرئيس
السيسي اعتقد اولا هو اولا كلمه انقلاب
غير دقيقه هي كانت ثوره بكل المعاني خرج
فيها الملايين ده اولا ثانيا مطلب من
الازهر
ليس له علاقه بارضاء النظام فالامر هنا له
علاقه بوضع وصوره الاسلام في العالم اجمع
فما نرى من معدلات الارهاب وعجز الازهر
كمؤسسه او كقيادي للازهر ان تضع مفهوما
للدين يقاوم هذا التطرف الفكري ونرى
التطرف
يزداد بجنون وع الناحيه الاخرى يزداد
الالحاد ايضا فهو عجز رهيب لهذه المؤسسه
وعلى راسها
قيادتها ممثله في الشيخ الازهر فسيدي
الفاضل دعني اقول لك نقطه واضحه هنا ان
شيخ الازهر يظن انه اذا خرج لعالم ليقول
له ان الاسلام يدعو للسلام وانه دين
السلام ان ذلك يكفي لاقناع العالم ولكن
الحقيقه انهم حينما يرون الازهر يدرسوا
اشياء مثل قتل المرتد والرجم واعلان
القتال على غير المسلمين عرض عليهم اما
الاسلام او الجزيه او القتل واخذ نسائه
سبايه لا ينتظر شيخ الازهر بعد كل ذلك
التدريس الرهيب ان يقول له العالم ان
الاسلام دين سلام فهناك خلل في طريقه
التفكير وهناك عجز عن مواجهه القضيه التي
تسببت ليس في مشكله النظام المصري فحسب بل
للعالم اجمع وعل الحق لكلمه الحق ان
الرئيس السيسي حصل على احترام العالم اجمع
بعد مواقفه في مواقفه في مواجهه
الايديولوجيه الارهابيه ولكن شيخ الازهر
بدل من ان يعترف ان هناك خللا هو يصر على
ان تدريس هذه الاشياء مثل اكل لحم المرتد
وارضاع الكبير وغيرها انها اشياء ليس فيها
اي مشاكل ويظن ان ان ان العالم سينص له
اعتقد ان الصحفيين الذين يطالبون
باستقالته على حق في ذلك طيب يعني المشكله
مع المؤسسه وليس مع مع مع شخص احمد الطيب
وهذه المؤسسه قائمه منذ زمن بعيد
موجو اي دعني اسال الشيخ محمد الصغير اهلا
بك معنا بالاستديو بمقار ما اسباب هذه
الحمله على الازهر فهمنا الان من السيد
توفيق ان المشكله مع الازهر وليس مع مع
السيد الامام احمد الطيب هل توافق هذه
النقطه الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله السيد توفيق حميد ومن قبله عبد
الفتاح السيسي عنده مشكله مع الاسلام كدين
وليس مع الازهر كمنظمه وكلام السيد توفيق
فيه اغاليط كثيره تحتاج الى وقت الى
تفنيدها ليس وقته الان فقد تعمد خلط الخمر
باللبن الذي يسبى ويقتل الان هم نساء حلب
ونساء سوريا ونساء الموصل وليس نساء
واشنطن التي يعيش فيها الان ثم الاسلام
الذي رضي عنه الغرب ورضي عنه واشنطن ليس
هو اسلام عبد الفتاح السيسي لانه عبد
الفتاح السيسي اتهم كل المسلمين المليار
و300 مليون اتهمهم بانه قتله لذا حاز رضا
توفيق حميد ومن يعمل معهم الان اما مشكله
عبد الفتاح السيسي من وجهه نظري مع احمد
الطيب ليست مشكله دينيه وان كان السيسي
عنده مشكله مع الاسلام كدين لكن المشكله
مع اداء الشيخ احمد الطيب الشيخ احمد
الطيب نظرا لانه ينتمي الى اسره عريقه جدا
في الصعيد لها ناس تحدثه ثم انه ينتسب الى
اكبر طريقه صوفيه ايضا ففيه الرقه الصوفيه
ثم خلفيته الدراسه في فرنسا وفي السربون
هذه الاشياء تجعل الشيخ احمد الطيب لا
يسير بالقوه المطلوبه في فلك الانقلاب
العسكري لذا عبد الفتاح السيسي يريد
الحصان الرهوان الذي يجري ويسابق وامله ان
ياتي الى مشيخه الازهر الشيخ علي جمعه
الذي يقول اضرب اقتل في المليان طيب دكتور
عبد المقصود المستغرب انه رغم تقديم
الازهر كل ما يمكن لنظام السي كما كما
اسلفنا سابقا من امثله رغم هذا يتعرض ل
شضايا وانتقادات لاذعه سواء كان من الرئيس
السيسي او حتى من الصحفيين المحسوبين عليه
في مثال اخر كما حصل ايضا مع احمد هليل في
الاردن عندما تحدث لمصلحه الملك
ولمصلحته كيف تفسر هذه المفارقه استخدام
المؤسسه الدينيه في مكان والاطاحه بها في
مكان اخر
سيدي بدايه اقول لك ان الازهر
وشيخه وقفوا الى جانب مصر وليس الى جانب
عبد الفتاح السيسي وما حدث في مصر ثوره
وليس انقلابا كما تصر قناتكم على ذلك اما
ما قاله ضيفك الولايات المتحده فكلامه
98% منه خطا في خطا فليات الى ازهرنا وكل
من يتقول على الازهر الشريفي يحضر الينا
ويحضر ما ندرسه اما هذا الهراء الذي يقال
فلا علاقه للازهر الشريف به وبالتالي فان
شيخ الازهر والازهر الشريف لا يدرس مثل
هذا الكلام الذي قاله ضيفك من الولايات
المتحده وهو وانا اسف لذلك انه لم يحضر
الينا ولم يستمع الى شيوخنا ولم يحضر
محاضراتنا بل نحن ندعو كل من يهاجم الامام
البخاري او غيره او المؤسسه الازهريه ان
ياتي الينا دعوناكم ودعو العالم كله ان
ياتي الينا ليحاجوكم
ما قال القران الكريم وانا او اياكم لعلى
هدى او في ضلال مبين فليات من يحاجج
الازهر الينا او فلنذهب نحن اليه لنحافه
ويتبين الحق من الباطل اما هذا الكلام
الذي يقال من ان الطلاق الشفوي او الطلاق
التحريري او كذا او كذا هذه لا يقولها
الرئيس السيسي او شيخ الازهر او اي احد
كان لا احد في الكون كله ستطيع ان يفرض
رايا دينيا على الازهر الشريف جيد استاذ
توفيق حميد سمعت ما قاله الدكتور عبد
المقصود وانت قلت في معرض اجابتك الاولى
انه هؤلاء الاعلاميون على حق في انتقاد
شيخ الام ازهر هل مجرد تصريح بسيط من
الرئيس السيسي يفهم بهذه الطريقه وبالتالي
تفتح الابواب امام هذا الانتقاد الواسع
والذ الذي ربما لم يحصل في تاريخ مصر منذ
وصول العسكر في خمسينيات القرن الماضي على
هذه المؤسسه الدينيه الكبيره هل يكفي هذا
هذه الاشاره الصغيره لتكون ضوءا اخضرا
لحرب شعواء على المؤسسه الدينيه
الازهريه شوف حضرتك الهجوم ونقد الازهر
الازهر من فتره طويله قبل ان يقول الرئيس
السيسي كلمته كان هناك هجوم في كثير من
البرامج على المناهج الازهريه فلا نستطيع
ان نعزي ما حدث الى كلمه الرئيس السيسي
فقط فهناك هجوم مبني على اسس وانا اقول
لضيفك الكريم الذي اهمني ان اقول اني اقول
كلاما غير دقيق وانه يدعوني او يدعو كل من
يختلف معه للمناظره انا اقبل المناظره
ولكن حتى تتم هذه المناظره اطلب منه شيئا
واحدا لاثبات اني خطا ان يخرج هو او شيخ
الازهر افضل شيخ الازهر على العالم اجمع
ليقول لهم ان قتل المرتد مرفوض في الاسلام
وان قتل تارك الصلاه مرفوض وان الرجم شيء
مرفوض همات السيس كف لاطلاق هذه الاق
والحم
الش حين يخرج شيخ الازهر لينكر هذه
الاشياء حين ذاك ساقول انا مخطئ لكن حتى
يظهر بشخصه وينقد هذا الفكر الذي تستخدمه
داعش وغيرها والذي رفض هو تكفره اعتقد
انهم لا يستطيعوا ان يعيبوا من ينقد هذه
الاشياء فكيف تدرس عنفا وتنتظر من الناس
ان يقولوا قائل شيخ الازهر هو شيخ الازهر
لم ينقد هذه الامور اصلا عندما جلس عن
يمين السيسي يوم اعلان الانقلاب وعندما
ذهب الى مؤتمر شيشان هذا هو شيخ الازهر
لماذا الان الحمله
ضده
كان منتظر منه ومن البدايه الرئيس السيسي
كان واضحا في مطالبته بتغيير الخطاب
الديني وتطويره وكان منتظر منهم وصبر
الجميع عليه والعالم كله كان ينتظر موقفا
من الازهر وليس فقط الرئيس السيسي وعجزهم
عن ذلك هو ما يشوه صوره الاسلام فانا
اراهم هم المسؤولون اولا عن ظاهره
الاسلاموفوبيا شكرا توفيق حميد الشيخ محمد
الصغير ما تداعيات وما الات هذه الحمله
على شيخ الازهر برايكم هل سيستجيب لهذه
الضغوط ويستقيل وما تداعياته على المؤسسه
الازهر هذه المرجعيه السنيه في في في
الوطن العربي كمرجع قمه الشيعيه ومرجع
الفاتيكان المسيحيه احنا اليوم جئنا
للحديث عن عبد الفتاح السيسي في معرض
كلامه عن الطلاق الشفهي اللي هو يعتبر رده
عن الثوابت ولكن الضيف من واشنطن اصر على
الحديث على حد الرده ويبدو على حد المثل
المصري اللي على راسه ط بطها بيحسس عليها
خايف توفيق حميد من موضوع الرده لا ادري
سبب ذلك لكن ما تفضلت به ا احمد الطيب شيخ
الازهر ليس اكبر على النظام العسكري من
هشام جنينه رئيس الجهاز المركزي للمحاسبات
احمد الطيب لم يخالف العسكر ومشى في
ركابهم في كل شيء وحقق لهم كل ما يريدوا
ولكن هو لا يتنفل هو لا يفعل ما هو اكثر
فهم يريدون منه المزيد هذا النظام لا يرضى
بالموافقه وانما يريد التطبيل الدائم
وتداعياتها على المؤسسه الدينيه باختصار
لو سمحت تداعياتها على المؤسسه الدينيه
لابد ان يرجع احمد الطيب الى ربه ويعرف ان
المتغطي بالعسكر عريان شكرا لك الشيخ محمد
الصغير مستشار وزير الاوقاف المصري السابق
اشكر من واشنطن توفيق حميد الباحث في
الشان المصري وعبر الهاتف من القاهره
الدكتور عبد المقصود باشا استاذ الدراسات
العليا في جامعه الاز